i really want to start with the sincere
you guys were both so fantastic in this
um i just want to say thank you for your
work um if someone has actually never
seen anything that you've done before
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why
well being the ricardo's uh quite
obviously uh because uh you know
it's a it's a beautiful recreation of a
time and place but also just a
a sort of multi-layered beautiful drama
about a comedy
yes being the ricardos
absolutely
got it one of the things that i think um
which is amazing is that how much uh
i love lucy invented so many things that
we still use today and i think sorkin
does such a great job with his script
sort of educating the audience but also
entertaining then again this is aaron
sorkin he's a genius um can you sort of
can you sort of talk about um his script
and maybe some of the things you learned
that you really didn't know
well i think we both learned a lot about
our individual uh characters about
vivian slash ethel you know in addition
to bill
slash fred mertz um and yes uh
genius is a word that's
tossed around a lot
in in our business and in life in
general but it does apply to the maestro
aaron sorkin who by the way
has become
really one of the great film directors
as well now in in the last uh uh
whatever several years
uh always been a genius writer since uh
you know i had the good fortune to join
the cast of his first broadway play a
few good men as an understudy
31 years ago so that's that's how far
back my acquaintance with his genius
goes and uh
the thing that i think people sometimes
uh
underestimate or or don't emphasize
besides his intellect is is his heart
and the and the the depth of the stories
that he's always telling
do you want to add anything
well for me i i had no idea about
anything relating to lucy's affiliation
with the communist party that was
complete news to me so that was really
interesting to learn about
one of the other things about this uh uh
which i found so fascinating is the way
he takes that iconic line lucy i'm home
and spins it into a whole new meaning
with this script and with this movie can
you sort of talk about that aspect if
you don't mind
one of the most if not the most
important thing to lucy was home that's
all she wanted was to have a home to be
home to create a home so it is
beautifully done in the film it's very
um emotional and it hits so many layers
uh for for lucy's character and for the
story in general
yeah that's the kind of genius of of of
aaron's that uh that i was referring to
his you know his ability to find those
different levels of of depth within the
story and you know he he spent
after
he was finally convinced to do this
screenplay by todd black he spent a year
and a half you know before he felt like
he had a script that he was ready to
start sending out to actors
i i faced that badly sorry
i i understand i got to stop there i'm
just going to say again you guys did
such great work thank you for giving me
your time and good luck with the rest of
your speed dating
thank you